con más vacunas aplicadas que en
cualquier otro país
el presidente joe biden llega a sus 100
días en la presidencia con una promesa
cumplida más de 230 millones de dósis
inoculadas y un 29 por ciento de la
población totalmente inmunizada el
tapabocas ya no es necesario al aire
libre para los inmunizados guardias y
quiero ser totalmente claro si estás en
una aglomeración como en un estadio en
una conferencia o en un concierto
todavía debes usar el tapabocas wear más
el partido de baile en el demócrata
presentó una protesta de reforma a la
policía en el congreso que ya tiene el
visto bueno de la cámara de
representantes pero aún enfrenta el
desafío del senado el mandatario exhortó
a los legisladores a probarla tras la
condena al ex policía derecho ven por el
asesinato del afroamericano george lloyd
hayden tiene el gran reto de la ola
migratoria proveniente de centroamérica
de enero a marzo se ha registrado un
aumento de 100.000 detenidos en la
frontera algo que le ha costado críticas
de los republicanos pero para atenderlo
la vicepresidenta kamala harris anunció
una ayuda de 310 millones a centro
no obstante presentó una reforma
migratoria al congreso que propone un
camino a la ciudadanía para los 11
millones de indocumentados que se estima
hay en eeuu también debe ser negociada
con los republicanos en el / senado
además de cumplir con la promesa del
plan de estímulo de 1,9 billones de
dólares
bailén ha aumentado el salario mínimo de
725 a 15 dólares la hora el presidente
regresó a eeuu al acuerdo climático de
parís y retomó las negociaciones sobre
el pacto nuclear con irán además ha
fijado a china y rúsia como sus grandes
adversarios internacionales aplicando
sanciones contra el último por un
supuesto ciberataque y el envenenamiento
al opositor al ex y naval